vincent merci d'être là vinson vous avez
67 ans vous êtes père de huit enfants en
octobre 99 vous fait opérer du coeur
l'opération se complique il meurt est
déclarée cliniquement mort pendant
quarante minutes
vous êtes mort pendant quarante minutes
25 c'est incroyable les médecins
essaient le ranimer
et ils y parviennent au bout de 40
minutes mais vous êtes vraiment déclaré
mort pendant les quarante minutes ils se
retrouvent collé au plafond et vous
pouvez voir et entendre les médecins
c'est ça qui sépare exactement alors
qu'est donc là vous voyez votre corps
mais vous vous êtes ailleurs
alors évidemment je suis là c'est là
haut perchée évidemment six mois juste à
côté c'est un petit peu en vision
panoramique ou ''evidemment on reçoit
toute l'information dans laquelle en
écrire l'environnement dans lequel on
est à la grande difficulté de se savoir
à ce moment là quelle est la réalité
exactement à ce que je suis vraiment ou
bien je suis dans un état de conscience
un peu particulier et de ce fait je me
suis quand même posé la question en
apercevant évidemment et en attendant
alors évidemment la vision est tout à
fait panoramique et en même temps tous
les sens sont multipliées presque à
l'infini c'est à dire j'avais la vision
je pouvais voir ce qu'il y avait autour
de héros delà des murs et au delà de ce
qui était circonscrit dans l'art de sept
blocs opératoires sont les gens tous les
ans on se demande
oui honte on est mort qu'est-ce qui se
passe est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on souffre
est ce qu'on se retrouve ou qu'est ce
qu'on voit qu'est ce qui se passe alors
dans cet état là à ce moment là quand
vous décoller quand vous quittez votre
enveloppe
simplement il ya il ya une chose
extraordinaire c'est qu'on se sent très
bien on est au delà de la réalité dans
laquelle on est dans ses souffrances on
vient justement de quitter on est dans
un moment de plénitude où il n'y a pas
vraiment l'inquiétude on se pose pas la
question 2 voilà et évidemment quand je
pouvais voir au delà de ces murs je
pouvais entendre par exemple une
infirmière qui est en train de vous
entendiez les gens quand même ah oui oui
tout à fait je pouvait même lire dans
les pensées des gens te fait non pas
discutés avec eux n'ont pas l'intérêt
l'inter intervenir dans quoi que ce soit
mais je pouvais évidemment participer
aux conversations qui se
les demandes mois et dont est donc vous
êtes quand vous étiez dit dis donc mort
vous sentiez bien
absolument c'est un état vraiment le
plénitude absolue ou là ou là il n'y a
plus du tout là le problème de la
maladie ou de la pathologie qui fait
souffrir
ah ouais et en plus son appel n'a pu la
conscience du corps dans qui nous
enveloppe pire on est dans une dimension
tout à fait particulier qu'est ce qu'on
voit quand on est mort alors qui c'est
quoi la première vision qu'est ce qui se
passe que tout le monde nous parle d'une
lumière blanche
alors oui alors évidemment juste après
quand on a accepté cet état d'âme pour
moi je parle pour moi il ya d'autres
expériences qui sont déjà dans
différentes moi je suis physiquement
quand j'ai accepté mon état demain si
c'est ça la mort
je les accepte je m'accepte comme ça et
je suis parti dans ce fameux tunnel que
qui est raide et réécrit par des cris
dans l'absolu mais l'expérience avec
cette lumière blanche qui au fond d un
très vite à vous à nous des roadsters
tout ça ça va être la laps de temps et
puis le une correspondance terrestre on
est dans un coquet new year blanche et
qu'est ce qui se passe et dans la
lumière blanche bien là j'étais face à
quelque chose qui est incroyable c'est
quand elle m'a pénétrait c'est une
viande blanche parce qu'elle m'a pénétré
j'avais l'impression de ressentir le
l'amour de 200000 maman qui me disait à
sanaa un instant pardon je t'aime
voilà voilà et donc ça disent qu'ils
sont tellement puissant que on peux pas
le décrire autrement que par ces mots la
c6 au delà de la raison humaine au delà
du comparative tout simplement alors
justement vous étiez tellement bien on
va l'envahir on a pu leur dire qu'on
vous étiez cliniquement mort oui vous
êtes sentie tellement bien
qu'aujourd'hui donc vos priorités ont
changé vous donner des conférences sur
le sujet expérience de mort imminente et
vous accompagner les gens en fin de vie
à ne plus avoir peur parce que pour vous
est-ce que j'ai une question qui va être
bête est ce que votre mort a été plus
beaux moments de votre vie pour
l'instant exactement c'est l'un des plus
beaux moments de ma vie et je veux des
cas ce moment là effectivement on
ressent une telle plénitude que
d'ailleurs tous les expériences heures
les gens qui vivent ces gens
d'expérience ne peuvent pas oublier ça
c'est impossible c'est gravé à vie et ce
qui est étonnant c'est que on a
l'impression quand on décrit quand on
parle de cette expérience convient de la
vivre ou dix secondes avant et qu'on est
toujours dedans
ben moi personnellement cette expérience
n'est pas finie elle continue encore
comment elle continue de façon un peu
très particulière où il ya des moments
c'était très compliqué tout au début de
savoir dans quelle réalité j'étais mais
ce que c'était de l'autre côté où
j'étais encore là effectivement c'était
dans cette ce doublage des choses qu'il
fallait que tu me détermine et et quand
vous êtes revenu à la vie juste vincent
comment ça s'est passé
bah ça a été un peu complexe parce que
le duo merde c'est fou merde merde parce
que je pari de revenir déjà non alors
c'est vrai que voyage que j'essaie je
suis partie 40 minutes vous l'avez dit
mais pour moi ça représente un an et
demi deux ans une réalité terrestre
ouais c'est fou donc j'ai visité
évidemment j'ai visité j'étais un peu
initié pour comprendre l'information qui
m'a été donnée
une information qui est qui qui sépare
de toutes ces plantes de toutes ces
niveaux si strates voulait de la
conscience humaine du plus dur du plus
vil plus plus terrible au plus
emblématiques voilà et c'est vrai que le
mot pour résumer ça c'est le mot amour
dans toute son site dans toute sa
rigueur et surtout dans speed sont
inconditionnalité dur c'est au delà de
la reine de la compréhension humaine et
et vincent et bah écoutez franchement
plus d'un cent quelqu'un vraiment
complètement sens et on peut vous le
dire
et voilà ce qui nous a décrit nous on en
a parlé voilà cette semaine avec la
production
et alors on nie pas que ça nous a donné
envie de courir mais ça nous assure que
c'est vrai c'est apaisant et vous êtes
apaisant appartement vraiment hébreu
l'anversoise s'appelle brad au pinceau